suis à paris vendredi dernier vers 15
heures sur la ligne 8
un garçon d'une vingtaine d'années yeux
clairs cheveux bouclés prince ces vagues
mais signe distinctif ils lisaient du
jean paul sartre les efforts de la jeune
femme sous le charme ont payé elle a
annoncé ce matin que l'inconnu s'étaient
reconnus et qu'il avait pris contact
avec elle affaire à suivre
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon ça me rappelle qu'à ce stade
il ya eu un temps on a eu des coups de
foudre
oui j'en ai dit oui mais là dans le
métro ce qu'il faut pour le métro déjà
vous avez jamais un coup de foudre
bernard monter la garde de nice jamais
dit sur la chaîne 15 mai alors je bouge
en ruine d'un mètre 95 je vous jure je
l' ai vu il m'a vu et je vous jure qui
s'est passé un truc alors que la foudre
nous a séparés et quand j'ai regardé il
était plus là en messie venu qu'un jour
tous les jours à la même heure à la
garçonne mais sur lui eh ben je pourrais
le dessiner aujourd'hui encore tellement
je me souviens de ce visage
ah ouais mais je suis sûr que j'étais
circonstances à une personne rousse d'un
mètre 95 qui doit être lue devant les
cheveux blancs mais demande à la cour
d'aller jamais 18 ans c'est dans une
gare était constellée des locomotives
match
[Musique]
alors oui des fines
je trouve ça trop mignon parce que en
fait champoux est ce que vous aviez eu
un coup de foudre vous comme ça vous
avez retrouvé la personne après oui bah
oui avec mon chéri j'ai eu un coup de
foudre accroché bah oui c'est pas vrai
mais mais mais c'est moins original pas
cité dans une c'est quoi vous délasser
dans un métro c'est trop mignon
il ya des discothèques dans ce n'est pas
bon les épices rares d'amour c'est trop
mignon comment est ce que vous êtes
rencontrés j'ai écrit une lettre dans la
sauce émane d'un coup de feu comme ça
dit la vérité mais j'y crois maintenant
quoi oui ça m'est arrivé moi encore fait
bah oui ou alors ben hiba le racontez
vous connaissez par coeur je vous ai dit
james bond ce connard ouais bon soir
attention vous aime d'un coup je sais
mais attention
alors ils sont des vases poli je dis non
oui alors j'y crois ou de [ __ ] c'est
vrai que le moment où vous regards se
croisent et une attirance est tellement
forte qu'on s'embrasse
je n'ai vécu non avec steam avec ma
femme est quoi oui non et si vous avez
pas rater la boucle du beau du bon et
c'est vrai qu'on s'est attirée de paso
irrémédiable non un très bon je vous
jure que c'est vrai c'est le désir et
conan c'est fou ça c'est le désir sinon
les analyses rfm landes d'amour la cdu
on pouvait pas y échapper non ces petits
riens je veux que c'est vrai c'est
incroyable que ça va c'est fou et et
vous géraldine avec moi j'ai eu un coup
de chaud absolue pour qui l'état pour
gagner pour monter en wagnon pour danny
way je les ai vus c'était une sorte
d'évidence away un choc ou un
tremblement intéressés comme un
tremblement de terre paris 6 poitiers
pont sur la maine jamais quoi il m'avait
pas vu et moi je les ai vus j'ai trouvé
qu'il était beau drôle intelligent
spirituelle qu'il avait tout pour lui et
alors je suis tombée folle amoureuse de
lui dans la seconde à cellules et c'est
vous qui avez été le chercher
alors après on s'est un petit peu parlé
après du coup il a il en a convenu que
c'était quand même pas mal qu'on se
retrouverait fort et vous bernard
montiel jamais moi j'y crois pas au coup
de foudre mal ça serait pas ça se
travaille il faut voir je vous dis alors
moi je le 10 août et les spirit vous je
vous le dis comme je le pense
savent lire et cela me fait beaucoup
beaucoup de peine vous ne rêvez plus
vous ne vivrez plus et vous jure que
c'est vrai c'est pas salé mis votre isis
sur ce il encore dit
séville est en mode dont sony est en
mode avion depuis des années est en
train de vivre des moments uniques
je vous le dis les gens ont saisi est en
confinement n'a pu 10 978
c'est vrai je le dis dans mes seins sans
rigoler ou ça c'est la vérité voilà oui
j'ai trop peur de souffrir
oui c'est vrai j'ai pas à chaque fois
j'étais très très très forte qu'est ce
qui s'est passé est ce que vous avez des
expériences difficiles mais à chaque
fois parce que vous savez l'amour quand
on se donne comme ça complètement c'est
c'est arrivé quand ça finit mal
mais comme chacun c'est effrayant très
grande douleur
j'ai du mal à m'en remettre c'est vrai
j'ai beaucoup de mal à m'en remettre je
sais j'ai l'air toujours rigolo enfin
rigolo normes et bonne humeur
je montre que cet himalaya dernier
derrière ce sourire oui on les loge
c'est d'ailleurs sa salade
non est ce qu'il ya une grande solitude
entre blessures il ya de vraies grandes
gueules sur une très grande solitude
enfin bon j'aime bien la musique qui va
avec où en êtes vous êtes seul bernard
oui je suis seul et je le regrette et vu
mon caractère ça va pas s'arranger
vraiment vous pouvez penser que vous
terminerez le sol oui alors je me
demande toujours qui va pousser le
chariot modèle mamie à l'ehpad en a déjà
prévu que pour vous vous même parce que
vous êtes gentils avec moi enfin pousser
les deux autres achoppaient on est on
est dans un moment d'émotion c'est vrai
c'est que c'était sa date à ça remonte à
quand votre plus belle histoire d'amour
la dernière ou la plus belle la plus
belle il ya longtemps il ya très
longtemps parce que vous marier parce
que j'y crois plus en fait c'est ça le
problème pourquoi écouter nos mes
ambitions
aujourd'hui bernard oui c'était quand
cette histoire d'amour
bernard la dernière sérieusement il ya
il ya maintenant dix ans et alors et
alors depuis celle d r marc feld aisée
je vois du pays courait mais quelle que
soit l'histoire par les airs voyez quel
que soit 6 dans le désert oui bernard il
était il ya dix ans qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est vous qui avez décidé de
rompre ou c'est la personne qui est
parti non c'est moi qui ai foutu le
bordel pourront pas parce que j'avais
trop peur de l'investissement affectif
ça devenait trop sérieux j'ai eu peur et
j'ai foutu le bordel pourquoi vous avez
peur comme ça
de l'amour cyril j'ai tellement peur de
souffrir
non vraiment ça va l'allumer au bout de
dix ans au bout de dix ans vous êtes
passé commun de toi qu à personne
pourtant je suis âgée oui je m'en remet
jamais c'est quoi votre plus longue
histoire père n'a pas plus long de
l'histoire
oh là là mon dieu c'est dur ce que vous
me demandez je crois que c'était la plus
longue histoire a duré six ans voilà six
ans c'était six ans magnifique mais vous
savez quand vous vous investissez
effectivement beaucoup après moi j'ai
peur et je casse tout et mon mauvais
caractère mais vraiment je fais tout
pour que la personne s'en aille
j'ai beaucoup de souffle une barre et
alors n'empêche j'ai dit tout ce que
j'ai dit oui l'argent rigoler ça fait du
bien bordel de merde